But first let us look at examples of the three kinds of semantic categories that
by point to. So here is a sentence in which by points to an agent. That
was written be Ashok. Actually, this particular sentence was written by David.
The second sentence, David went to New York by train, here by is pointing to
a conveyance. David stood by the statue. Here, by it is pointing to a location.
By the statue. So the use of the word by helped us, in that it
constrained the interpretation of Ashok to either an agent, conveyance or
location. It by itself doesn’t tell us whether Ashok is an agent or
a conveyance or location. We need some additional knowledge. Let us suppose that
the agent has an ontology of the world. The term ontology initially comes from
philosophy where it means the nature of reality. An artificial intelligence
determine ontology often reference to the conceptualization of the world.
The categories and terms of which I specify the world.
These categories have become the vocabulary of the knowledge representation. So
let us supposed that the agent has this ontology of the world.
The world is composed of things, and things can be agents or objects or
locations. Agents are people, and Ashok and David are examples of agents.
Objects can be conveyances. And trains and cars are examples of conveyances.
Obviously this is a very small part of someone's ontology about the world.
Now this ontology helps us decide that Ashok, in the first sentence,
is an agent. Let's see how. Here we have by Ashok, and
we know from the prepositional constraints that by can refer to an agent,
conveyance, or location. So the question now becomes, is Ashok an agent,
Ashok a conveyance, or Ashok a location? We can look into this ontology.
Ashok is people, which is an agent. So now we know,
that Ashok must be an agent. Similar the second sentence. Train can be an agent,
conveyance or location. Let's look at our ontology. A train is a conveyance. So
now we know the train is a conveyance. Similarly for statue.
Statue in this case specifies a location. Note that this analysis applies to
different prepositions, not just to by. Supposing this first sentence was,
That was written with Ashok. In which case, this preposition with will point to
Ashok either being a coagent or being an instrument. So again,
we now know that Ashok is a coagent in the sentence which
contain the preposition with. There is another important thing to note here.
Initially, when we were give this sentence, David went to New York by train,
we started doing bottom-up processing. David was a noun, went was a verb. But
pretty soon we shifted to top-down processing. As an example,
you already have this background knowledge, and this background knowledge tells
us in a top-down manner that by, here, can refer to an agent, a conveyance, or
a location. We also have this additional background knowledge, and
this background knowledge tells us that in this particular sentence.
The train describes frame to a conveyance, because train is a conveyance in this
ontology. So low-level bottom up processing generates queues,
which access probes into memory. Memory then returns knowledge like this,
and the processing becomes top down. The top down processing tells us how to
interpret the various words in this sentence, how to make sense of this story.